did you know that Gins are actually a
pretty good deal compared to Netflix or
Amazon Prime they seem expensive at an
average price of 50 bucks a month is
probably one of the highest
non-essential monthly expenses on many
Americans budgets but keep in mind the
gyms are very expensive to run High
utility bills fancy equipment trained
professionals the only way they can
afford all this stuff is by signing up
way more members than they can actually
accommodate at most gyms if just five
percent of their members showed up at
once they'd have to start turning people
away part of their business strategy is
to recruit customers who will rarely or
never use the service they pay for and
it works according to one survey 82
percent of gym members go less than once
per week and 22 percent stop going all
together after six months but keep
paying the good news is that if you're
one of the few who actually uses your
gym regularly you're getting a great
bargain generously subsidized by all
those other members who don't